foreign
today is I'm going to take you
on a on a tour of iconography
but I'm also going to do it very much in
the context of this conference
so it's important to understand that
because I'm going to to point to certain
things about the images that I'm going
to talk about and I'm going to try to
help you hopefully
see the structure of these images
and help you see how the structure of
these images
are related to the question of of
Consciousness the question of attention
the problem of the imaginal especially
that John has been bringing up in his
discussion
and how the language the visual language
of the church the spatial language of
the church
how it is a
kind of imaginal vision or imaginal
participation
in the the structure of reality so sorry
use these words but
it's important to understand that what
I'm about to say is in no way trying to
take away from the theological aspect
the the the uh
the the fact that these images are meant
to help people worship to participate
you know to have a
reminders of holy images of holy things
and so it's very important because this
is that aspect is very very important to
me
but because our conference is about
Consciousness I think it's it's it's uh
it's important to try to connect it
together and to also help you see
how it is that religious language and
religious imagery can help us uh peer
into the the problem or the question of
our experience in the world and
how we deal with that
and so the image you're looking at right
now is an image called the deisys
and the Deus is
the basis of Christian art
that is it is you'll see I'm going to
take you through the steps in terms of
the history of the images I'm going to
show you old images how the image
develops but also how it really does
become the central image of the the
Christian Church up to
the Renaissance and so a lot of things
happened in the Renaissance which
transformed the language of religious
art made it far more
um
say sentimental more dramatic a lot of
things were brought into the art to
showcase the talent of the artist to and
so one of the things that happened is
that the ancient language of the church
that was developed organically and and
universally for
1200 1300 years slowly started to slip
away from people's memory and so an
image for example that everybody knows
which is you know the Michelangelo's
creation of God of Michelangelo's God's
creation of of uh of Adam you know with
the two fingers showing it's an absolute
anomaly in the history of Christian art
it's a complete freak thing that shows
up and although we tend to think of it
as
an image a religious image of showing
God
creating Adam it's actually a complete
aberration which which actually never
even
gave fruit in the church so there are no
other versions of that image whereas a
traditional language is more like a
poetic form
as it installs itself it creates these
patterns and then these patterns like a
folk dance for example is a good way to
understand it there are patterns of
movement that get taken up by people and
that we can recognize in different folk
dances although there's some difference
there's a Common Language of coming
together of ways to move and that is the
manner in which we have to understand
traditional languages of art they are
participative they're there to bring you
into the community bring you into a
common
experience and in the in the case of the
the Christian art this is something
which happened very
surprisingly in an organic manner so if
you had gone into a church in England or
a church in Syria in the year 1000 or
1100 you would have found your way there
would have been difference there would
have been some cultural difference but
you would be able to recognize the
characters and the figures and you'd be
able to find your way through the
imagery that was presented
and we don't have texts
there are no texts that tell us this is
how the images have to be it is
something which happened in a very
organic Manner and through ways in
mechanical causes that are very
mysterious to us like were there bands
of artists traveling the world
exchanging with each other we don't even
know how it it happened but it happened
um
and so the image of the diocese is an
image that you still will find today in
an Orthodox Church often on the
iconastasis it is the central image of
the church and what it represents is
Christ stand in the center
often on a throne for sure in a kind of
royal
stance Christ is actually dressed as a
Roman Senator as a Roman nobleman
and he is holding in his left hand a
book
and with his right hand he is gesturing
he's blessing but just just think that
he's gesturing with his with his right
hand
and so he is the center and then from
the center then we have series of saints
and those that are close to Christ are
always the same
so we have on the right hand of Christ
Mary the Mother of God when I say that
when I'm going to say right and left by
the way it's always going to be from the
point of view of the image okay because
the point of view of Christ so on
Christ's right you will have the mother
of God Mary and then on his left you
will have Saint John the Baptist Saint
John The Foreigner
or or and on his right you will have
Saint Peter on his left you will have
Saint Paul
and then after that it can be more
there's more flexibility in terms of the
types of saints that will that will be
represented next to him
and often also there will be uh Angels
but we'll get to the angels later
so the image of the DSS is an
eschatological image
it is an image of the end of time
it is an image
of the totality of all things
that's better to think about it that way
so we think about the end of times
we have funny scenarios that play in our
mind
the best way to understand the end of
time is to understand it as it's this
the place or the time in which all
things are now revealed everything that
is to be revealed
has been revealed so it's all things the
totality of all things
so Christ is on its throne
is also a judge
and those that are next to him they are
emanating from him they are also
interceding towards him
in this totality
of all things
and so this image
we're going to get to the meeting slowly
so just try to remember as much as you
can but don't worry I will I will uh
come back to it
so this image is one of the oldest
images that we have you can change the
slide
so as soon as churches started to be
built after the persecution
this image appears right away so these
are sent these in the churches the
oldest churches we have where these
decorations are still up are in Rome and
so we find in the fourth Century this
eschatological image so here again we
have Christ
sitting on a throne
like I told you with his right hand he's
gesturing in his left hand he's holding
a script a book a scroll it can have
different shapes and then on his
so now it flips though we'll see why it
flips on one side of him you have to say
Paul he's here
on the other side you have Saint Peter
he's there
and they are receiving crowns
and those that which is crowning the two
one is known or understood to be the
Church of the Jews and the others
understood to be the Church of the
Gentiles
and above them you see
these strange animals
with wings
so the reason why you have these strange
animals with wings is that
this is
it's a revelation it's not and that's
why when you think about the end of
times I I trying to help you see that
it's the revelation of all things
so those beasts that you see with the
wings those are the beasts that we find
in division of Ezekiel where Ezekiel has
this vision
of God we had he actually has a vision
of the Throne of God
and he sees these four beasts a lion an
eagle a man and a bull
and that vision
so all of this gets brought together in
this space so
now we again see that Chariot or the
Throne of God but now Christ is sitting
in The Chariot or Throne of God that
Ezekiel Saw in the Book of Ezekiel
and surrounding him are these four
aspects
now the four beasts in Ezekiel
they are four aspects of the divine
revelation
but they ultimately also come to
represent the four Gospels
so we understand
again Christ in the center
and now
pointing to him emanating from him can
see it from both ways that is him being
the source of these Saints and of these
images or him also being the culmination
of these images in the center okay so
you can see it going out or coming in uh
and so the the four gospels is a one
aspect of that so we understand that
Christ is beyond the Bible I hope
everybody still believes that Christ is
beyond scripture Christ is a person
Christ is a revelation and that
revelation
is not fully contained
but appropriately contained into four
corners
right so four aspects which come to be
the four Gospels
okay so you have one in the middle then
you have four
outside that's it's really important
because when we're gonna get later
you're gonna start to see why that
matters it's a chariot
it's a it's a
it's a stable body
for the invisible
one which is behind the four
so you can understand it we'll get to it
later but you can understand it as the
ancient way that people understood the
world so you have the Dome of heaven and
then you have the square of the Earth
okay and it's just
for the same reason a table works
right for something to have a stable
manifestation you need four two sets of
opposites for it to hold together
uh and that's why it's also a chariot so
Chariot is more mobile but it still has
the four
wheels that stabilize the invisible one
which is behind it
all right so this so the original
decorations of churches right at the
outset at the in the fourth century were
based on the Book of Revelation
they were based on the apocalypse why
because the worshipers are participating
in the Kingdom
when they come to the church they are
participating in the
the all things
they are they're they are participating
actively in the final Revelation so we
still have interesting little memories
of that even now in for example the
Orthodox liturgy which when we come to
the final moment after the consecration
we thank God for all he has done and we
thank God
uh we thank God for
for the for the coming for the death for
the resurrection for the Ascension on
the right hand of God and the final
coming
as if it's already happened because this
is eschatological time you could say the
totality of all things is hidden
in now it's not just something that
happens at the end right you could say
that it's the final the final love or
the final Vision that's pulling all
reality
towards it
now
what does this have to do with with
consciousness
the way to understand this is to
understand the relationship between the
center
and that which is around it
so Christ is the focus point
and then from that Focus you will have
ah
a current moving in and a current moving
out
you'll have an aspect which is moving
towards Christ and an aspect which is
moving away from Christ
this is the way to understand
that the even the very first icon so
this is an image of the last judgment
it's an image also of the eschaton
so we have Christ in the center
right and you those who are Christian
will know the text and we it was read
yesterday it was actually read uh this
morning or was it we we read yesterday
sorry yeah when Scott presented the
The Abbey and so on his right hand he
has the Sheep
and on his left hand he has the goats
to those on the right he says come
to those on the left he says move away
okay
this is one of mine I put a few of my
icons because I thought some people want
to see them
um here again this is the same age we
have Christ
he is represented as the final
revelation of all things and on the one
side he's got the blessing hand and on
the other side he's holds the book with
one hand he says to the Sheep come with
the other hand he says to the goats move
away
and so we have to really understand that
as a
as an image of of reality itself
that is
you can understand it as a as as
attention even
so attention itself has
those two aspects to them
that is there's something there are
aspects that are drain that are say
concentration
and there are aspects which are
dissipation
and we can understand it as a pattern of
attention where we could understand it
as a pattern of everything that exists
right so a any group
has an aspect of it which is moving
towards its identity and this aspect of
it which is moving away from its
identity
in this image it's presented as negative
that is he says to the Sheep come
and he says to the goat move away he's
sending the goats to the fire and he's
bringing the Sheep into the kingdom
into the the place which is contained
but it's not necessarily negative
so go back go back actually go back up
to the first one
right so it's not necessarily negative
it can only be it can be seen just as a
moving out and a moving in
so
once you look at the characteristics of
those that are presented on the left
side and the right hand of Christ you're
going to start to notice that this is
what's
going on let's say
and so
the mother of God is represented so the
mother of God and Saint John The
Foreigner they are the two that preceded
Christ the two that pointed to him and
in the way they're represented they
represent they they manifest two
opposites they're seen as opposites from
each other
so the mother of God just look at him
you can see it and especially in that
you can see that the mother of God is
covered she is clothed right she is
hidden
and she is seen as the one who for those
who are traditional Christians right the
one who brings Mercy
right she's the one who also
if you look at her at her more
traditional stories she was hidden
inside the the holy of holies you know
she has the secret aspect to her
um
and it says in Scripture that when she
saw the things that were happening after
she gave birth to Christ it says she
gathered all the things in her heart
that's really important actually the
word gathers is symbolo it's related to
the notion of the way that I talk about
symbolism she gathered all these
multiple events into her heart
okay so that is the image of her on the
right side of Christ which is the side
that we saw before at the side of Mercy
the side that gathers the Sheep into the
kingdom
now on the left side of Christ we have
the wild man
who lives in the desert
who screams
to tell people to to repent
who takes people down into death into
the water
and so all these aspects of the opposite
of what she is is represented at these
two currents we could say that are on
the right hand and the left hand of
Christ so now the left hand which is
this move away that's pushing away from
the center is not necessarily bad in
itself right but you can see that that's
what it is right you can see the
difference between uh
if you know the story The Legend of how
the mother of God passes dies she she
reposes and then all the disciples
magically are gathered to her and like
through the air it's like this crazy
story so they're all gathered to her and
they are gathered around her as this as
this as this whole as this thing that is
surrounding the home of of Christ
all right and so how is Saint John
killed
he's split in two he's he's in half
right separated
right of course in in this case like I
said it's it's really to help you see
the difference between this gathering in
this pushing away
this gathering together and this
spreading apart this breaking apart okay
now
if we look at the other ones that are
next to him we'll find Saint Peter and
Saint Paul and again you'll have the
same structure repeated through
different images in them
who is Saint Peter
in relationship to Saint Paul Saint
Peter is the Apostle to the Jews right
he's the Apostle to those that are
inside
he's the one to whom Christ said you are
the foundation right you are the
foundation on which I'm going to build
my church
who is Saint Paul he is the Apostle to
the Gentiles he's the Apostle to The
Outsiders
and and you could even see it more in
Saint Paul because Saint Paul I think he
kind of knew what role he was playing
and so he he jokes around with that he
plays around with that he says that he's
the aborted apostle
he says that he is the least of the
Apostles he says that he is a
shape-shifter that he has all things to
all people he says he how does he
convert he falls off his horse backwards
and so it's like if you want a better
image of the left hand you would
struggle to to find it
uh
and interestingly enough you can see
even in Saint Paul and Saint Peter you
can actually now see the flip side or
the negative side of those two aspects
one which is the concentration and one
which is the dissipation
so what is the sin of Saint Peter
it's Pride right it's boldness
Saint Peter who says to Christ
it goes so far as to say to Christ you
don't you shouldn't you don't have to
die
that's a sin right
you don't have to break apart you can do
it we can hold it together
so it's interesting because it's quality
which is to be the foundation which we
see the be the one who stands up at
Pentecost and boldly proclaims and and
and and marks this first moment when the
church appears as a body
right is the same thing which leads him
to the pride
quality and the the say his his quality
and and his sin are related to the same
characteristic
and in Saint Paul
what is his problem or his sin
he says it's a thorn in the flesh
it doesn't tell us what it is it's very
interesting though to think about what
that means it's that you if you
understand that the notion of a thorn in
the flesh is related directly to the
fall it's a reference to Adam and Eve
falling and then encountering the Thorns
these multiple prickly things that are
many many many many points
the difference between one point and
many many many points that are on the
edge okay
so you have this concentration and this
dissipation we understand it as Mercy
pulling in and as judgment pushing away
all right
so what you're seeing like I said is an
image of how we interact with things how
we interact with the world and the the
center gathers them together right the
proper attention will always be moving
subtly between the unity and the
multiplicity of whatever it's engaging
with you will always be playing subtly
between the fact that something has one
identity and it also has multiple
aspects
and there's a dance like a dance between
that Gathering into one and that
spreading out into the many now
if you only have the many you have
decomposition right it's like if I can
if I only have this is this is also the
it's the joke of Justin Trudeau right
it's like if we just have diversity
that's called decomposition that's what
just diversity is
right if we only have Unity then we have
this problem of pride and the pride is
brittle and it's interesting also in in
Saint Peter because his pride the
crystallization
leads to him breaking apart so you see
the movement between the two it's super
interesting like Saint Peter it's always
the same story with Saint Peter right he
holds on he holds on too tight and then
crashes because he's holding on too
tight he says to Christ you know he says
to Christ like he will walk on the water
he's he can do it he's going to go out
and then
he falls he says to Christ who's the one
who told Christ he would never betray
you
and then who's the one who betrayed who
who Who's the one who who denies him
right and then it's the same the same
the the craziest one is when is when he
says to Saint Peter when he says to
Christ this is one of the wildest texts
in scripture he says to Christ you know
that you should you shouldn't die that
you know we can we can stop me from
dying uh no sorry if I don't it's when
he Christ says to Saint Peter you are
the you are the rock you are the
foundation which I'm going to build my
church says that the Saint Peter and
then Saint Peter says that Christ should
not die and then two verses later Christ
says Get Behind Me Satan it's like right
if you're looking in the text it's like
right next to each other he says to Paul
he says to Peter I'm going to found my
church on you and then it's like get
behind me Satan
right
and so I mean it's interesting to notice
and it this is it has to do with your
experience right I mean I hope everybody
has experienced that everybody has
experience they're like super strict
diet and then you're like I'm gonna do
this I got this I'm gonna I've got this
i got this and then you find yourself at
two in the morning you know eating a
piece of chocolate cake and you're like
what right and you know that that
tendency in you right the the problem of
holding on too tight
will lead to the breakdown
and then what's interesting about Saint
Paul is that I I noticed it too is that
his ex extreme his side will also lead
to a kind of weird opposite which is
that I I love Saint Paul you know
but he he he he brags a lot he really
brags it's really interesting and he he
also brags about his humility it's kind
of weird he's like the first like first
humble brag uh character but I think
it's related to this and there's
something about this movement from one
like one to the other you could say but
it also has to do with it has to do with
the way the red the left and the right
uh Works hopefully we can get to that I
hope so I want to show you another
aspect of this
so this image of Saint Peter and Saint
Paul gets developed in time and it has
different interesting aspects to it one
of the aspects that it develops is
something called the
the the tradicio clavis and there's the
thread the tradition the tradition of
the law and the tradition of the keys
and so what you find developing in the
western tradition this is one of the
very old uh a very old sarcophagus so
one of the thing that happens at the
outset in the first century is that
you'll see the opposite of the left and
the right but they they flip
and the reason why I think it's very
simple for the same reason that when I
said on the right side of Christ to you
guys you're like no that doesn't make
sense it's because the nature of the
right and the left is to invert
depending on your point of view and so
if I'm standing across from you my right
hand is on your let's say if I shake
your hand there's a Crossing that
happens so so the left and the right are
dependent on position
I actually think that that's actually
important in the interpretation of the
art and interpretation of what those
this those two perceptions we have how
they manifest themselves to us but I'm
not sure I'll be able you can watch a
video I put it up last week it's called
the left and the right hand of Christ
where I talk about these currents and
how they cross each other I'm not trying
to go into it too much but what I want
to show you is this particular aspect so
so here again is Christ in the center he
is The Middle on one side of him
he is giving a scroll
and on the the other side he's not doing
anything yet we'll see do you know what
he's standing on can anybody guess what
he's standing on
nope
all right let's go back two slides
all right what is he sitting on here
right do you does anybody remember in
scripture what it says
what is your throne
no well maybe but
Heaven is your throne
and the Earth is your footstool right
okay so go down
so he's standing on the cosmos actually
right and so the cosmos is under his
feet
it's a it's a it's a it's a it's an
allegorical figure I mean the Romans had
a lot of these you'll see the cosmos I
don't know if I have other images but
Cosmos actually is a figure that that
maintains itself in Christian art and we
still have Cosmos in in uh in the
Pentecost image for example we have this
image of Cosmos which represent
you'll see Christ sitting on a globe
you've seen that maybe before that same
deal right so different aspects of that
he's sitting on the totality I told you
that this image is about the totality of
all things it's not just an image of a
story it's not an image of a moment in
history where Jesus was had Peter and
Paul next to him and were giving them
these things right it is an image of the
finality and totality of all things and
so it becomes an image of
reality itself
and so here
this I want to show you just to show you
that these are really old like they're
not these are not things that I'm making
up
um you have here on now you have Christ
giving the law on one side and you don't
see it but he's giving
keys on the other side keep going down
we'll we'll get to it and you'll see it
now we see him giving the keys and then
keep going
all right now we see both at the same
time
so in one hand he's holding the key and
the other hand he's giving a scroll
right keep this is still like 14th
century uh go down yeah all right this
one we see it now completely developed
in terms of an image
so what is going on what is this what is
this what is this what is what is he
doing why is he getting the keys to
Saint Peter why is he giving the law to
Saint Paul
and the answer
is in the image of Christ himself
and so the image of Christ has two sides
I told you he's got one side where he is
addressing and he has another side in
which he's holding a book now these are
two aspects of the way that reality
presents itself to you again
so
addressing is direct
right if I talk to you if I bless you a
blessing is a direct relationship
it's like standing in front of you and I
say something to you and I bless you
a book is an indirect relationship to
anything you encounter it's indirect and
it's further away from the speech
but it has four aspects I can tell you
about the four this is also has to do
with the right and the left Crossing
each other so speaking is direct
but flexible
right writing is indirect
but fixed
so you have these four aspects playing
with each other
and you have to you have to it's hard to
keep it in your mind but
hopefully at some point if you keep it
in your mind enough you'll be able to
see and you'll be able to look at the
world and you'll start to think of let's
say right wing and left-wing politics
and you're going to start to realize
that that stuff is still there now
so there's an appeal to Authority and
this kind of
but a weird kind of flexibility in terms
of it's like why are right why do we say
sometimes right when people are
Libertarians like how does that work and
why is it that that the same people that
want
freedom and and equality will I want
really harsh State systems it's like
this these four things cross each other
this is direct and flexible but indirect
or further away or less relation to the
center if you like it that way but then
also fixed
okay different ways to try to get you to
see uh what is going on and so
what are key what are keys for
right they're locking unlocking opening
closing
these are that say the influence that
Christ gives to the church through Saint
Peter you have the power a direct power
to open and close
and then we have the scriptures
which are this indirect barrier
that holds things inside
so it it it acts as a buffer as a
barrier to avoid error or things from
coming in
but you need both together and that's
why the traditional church will always
have these two aspects together like we
need the living tradition of direct
relationship
you know from generation to generation
and then we need the exterior forms of a
hierarchy a church hierarchy we need
Scripture we need written liturgies we
need all this outer stuff
which is Harsh and a barrier
uh and the other one is direct
and this is
this is there so these opposites they're
there you can go down
a little more
like people have seen this image before
and so they're there in the image itself
like right in Christ's face especially
in this very famous image where we see
Christ you know with it with his right
eye looking straight
and there's a calmness let's say to the
right eye and then with his left eye
looking aloof looking off
and with also a kind of severity
to
to it so the eye of Mercy or the eye of
judgment you can see it that way if you
if you would like but it's important to
understand that
these two currents that are playing
around the center right they're not just
good and bad that's if you could at
least leave this discussion with
understanding it's not just good bad
it's more about it really is about
concentric and eccentric this
relationship the manner in which we
encounter the logos now remember that
Jesus is the Divine logos but the manner
in which we encounter the logos of
things or of groups or of whatever will
fractally have this same structure like
I said you have a basketball team it has
a purpose it has something which is
gathering a body together towards
something and there are elements in it
which will be merciful
and towards the players because if you
just impose nobody's a perfect
basketball player so you need a right
side of Mercy you need a left side
because you don't want people playing
golf in your basketball game so you have
to also push things away there's no
doubt about that
um and then you'll have you'll have
these different aspects which will come
together to
say to uh
to manifest the thing this is the
structure is I mean it's a universal
structure you see it the one of my
favorite uh quotes is from the poet Rumi
where he says
he says he says the
if the hand is closed all the time then
then you are paralyzed if the hand is
open all the time you are paralyzed but
the the the dance right is the very
subtle opening and closing of the hand
that is the dance that has to happen you
know John talks about optimal grip where
anytime I grab something there has to be
a subtle interplay between the manner in
which I'm holding it and the manner in
which I'm letting it go or or engaging
with it in a comfortable manner so I
have the right grip on what it is and
that's true for objects but it's also
true for any thing like it's true for
any like you know people that there are
perfectionists to an extent that they
will destroy the thing that they want
because of their perfectionism
right they they can destroy it and you
know the opposite is as well if someone
is too flexible and just lets anything
happen then they will also destroy the
thing that they want
the the dance or the
to find that play in between and that
image in the Bible or in traditional any
traditional Society will appear it's not
like the heart
about the heart
the central place the heart is not the
bumping the the pumping valve in your
body although it's part of it part of
the experience of the heart because that
it has that it has those two movements
in it it has a releasing and a gathering
but it is mostly the notion of the
center itself the notion of the center
of their being
all right so
okay so go down
right so now
you see I just want to show you a few
versions this is an image in Sicily same
again you keep going down
now here is an image in the church in
Egypt
and here we see it all kind of come
together where you have Christ on the
throne
he has the angels and he has the four
beasts can you see the four beasts
around him
you have the ain't the the eagle the
bull The Lion and the man and then up
it's a circular surface so it's hard to
see because it's actually a a demi half
circle so above you have can you
recognize them up there
John the change on the the Baptist and
then on the other side you have the
mother of God
all right you can keep going got a bunch
of versions of this I don't want to show
you too many so you can see different
versions of it you can represent it
in different ways you can represent it
like this
right so you can represent it the center
the right hand the left hand
or you can represent it like this
with the top and the middle
and then the right hand and the left
hand going down or being lower as you as
you see the body that is gathered into
the head or into the top
so this is uh this is I don't want to go
too much into it but this is one of the
images that bothered me from when I from
the first time I started looking at this
and I was really struggling with this
image because uh
you have this crossing over of the of
the qualities of the left hand and the
right hand that I that I'm trying to
suggest you a little I think I'm gonna
I'm afraid I'm gonna confuse you but you
can see that there's this crossing over
you could say the idea of something
saying that something is direct but
flexible
and that something is indirect but
static or hard and so in the image you
have this weird thing which is that on
the right hand of Christ you have the
Sheep the left hand of Christ you have
the goats on the right hand of Christ
you have this red angel
which will come to represent say Michael
and will actually come to be represented
with things like a flaming sword and
this Warrior that that's killing the
dragon and then on the other side you
have the Blue Angel which will come to
be represented as Saint Gabriel
ultimately in time and will be
represented with the lily as someone who
is presenting peace so it's like this
interesting crossing over of sides
this is universal right so you have it
in this in the and I just chose one
image of the Pharaoh
the Pharaoh has a straight rod and he
has a crooked rod and he crosses them
over like this
it's the same problem as the one we saw
above with so he has the straight and
the Crooked this will be look this will
be Universal you'll see it with the with
the King holding a scepter and a globe
they're all these different aspects of
this straight and round these two
opposites that face each other and that
represent the two Tendencies you could
say of uh of the logo sort of the of the
purpose of a being
all right keep going so this in
Christian Church it it comes to the
iconastasis and you can see this is a
recent agostasis that was made I don't
know 10 years ago I don't know but it's
a it's a contemporary one and you can
see the same structure as we saw in the
last judgment again
the same even the flip where you have
Christ
on his right you have the mother of God
on his left you have Saint John The
Foreigner and then on the edges you have
say Michael the red Angel and Gabriel
the Blue Angel
so the other image I showed you is from
the fourth Century this is from now like
this is a recent image and so the
language has been very Universal
all right keep going
maybe Skip One More
all right
now
this same structure
appears now the diocese or this same
structure of the center
as the logos and the two currents the
two sides appear in the crucifixion as
well now here they appear
clearly
you have two thieves
one of the thief looks to Christ and is
gathered into Christ and the other Thief
looks away from Christ mocks and then is
Cast Away
and so this is something which is there
in the very image of the crucifixion and
it it actually is carried all the way
into today and it's represented in for
example if you've ever seen a Russian
cross that has a foot bar that's crooked
like this
right that's what it's that's what it's
saying
that's talking about this
it says on the right hand it goes up
the left hand goes down
their left hand comes the right hand
comes closer the left hand moves away
you want to keep going
in this image this is one of the I'm
showing you very old images just so you
know that hopefully realize I'm not
making it up so this is one of the
oldest images of the crucifixion we have
from the 6th century and so you see
clearly on one side you see so now it's
flipped again sorry for the flip but
it's complicated because of that but
you'll see on one side of Christ you
have the thief looking towards Christ
and then on the other side you have the
thief looking away from Christ and then
you have the direct and indirect
do you know where that is in the image
where do you have direct and indirect in
the image
maybe a hint it's above
that is yeah that is that there's the
receiving and let's say piercing but
especially you have the Sun
on the side of the thief that's looking
towards Christ then you have the moon on
the side of the thief looking away so
you have the direct light and indirect
light
you also have with the sun and the moon
you have a lot of things you have the
the stable and the say the the straight
and then you have the changing and the
shifting because that's the nature of
the Moon of the the light of the moon
it's it's moving it doesn't it's not
stable it moves from light to Darkness
it's it's uh it's change
all right you want to go down
so I just want to show you a few
versions of of Mines because I thought
you would like to see it so here's the
crucifixion I did in wood
you want to go down one more so here's a
processional cross for a church
and again
you'll see again
the other relationship actually go back
to the rabulla gospel sorry go back a
few a few here actually you don't it's
not here go down sorry in mind all right
and so now you have again the two
figures
and the two figures have switched but
they also represent these two sides you
have Mother of God on the right hand of
Christ and then you have Saint John the
Theologian on the left hand of Christ
so like I said you can represent it like
this
like the like the dasis that I showed
you or you could represent it like a
pyramid and you can have the center the
purpose the logos above and then you can
have the two pillars
on the lower below so here's an image of
we call it a Proto Ascension but
actually I think it's just a cosmic
image of the relationship of of a
structure where you have Christ above
in the heavens
you have the Four Corners the four
beasts in the corners
and then you have actually you have the
Dome of heaven so you know he's standing
on the heavens you could say it that way
and then below here in the center is the
church
and then next to the church is Saint
Peter and Saint Paul acting as the two
pillars these two pillars of the church
and this is
the the two that the notion of these two
sides or these two pillars is something
which is like it's their way before like
it's not something that comes up in the
New Testament or in the church it's
there in the Old Testament who remembers
whether the two pillars of the Temple
yeah yakin and Boaz so the pillar has
two Temple two the the temple has two
pillars it has yakin which is means
foundation and then it has Boaz which
seems to refer to something like
strength but what's most important about
Boaz is that Boaz in scripture the the
person for whom it's named is the one
who married The Stranger he's the the
one who married Ruth who is a moabite
so you have the Apostle to the inside
and you have the Apostle to the outside
you have Saint Peter you have Saint Paul
right there
right at the outset in the architecture
of the temple okay so it's just
important that because sometimes I know
people are like Jonathan's just making
all this stuff up
yeah
all right and so this image which is
like we called something like a Proto
Ascension will be developed next slide
and then it becomes an actual image of
the Ascension
and here you're starting to see this
kind of whole structure come together
and so now you have Christ above
with the four the four uh with the
angels are actually down in the they're
in the Chariot it's hard to see
down here
so he is writing The ezekiel's Chariot
right
right he is on this stable
representation of of of the of God
he is up above
and
he's carrying up those crowns see those
two angels that are carrying up crowns
those two crowns that you saw in the
fourth Century being put on Saint Peter
and Saint Paul well here they're
represented as being given up towards
towards heaven if you remember the way I
talked about sacrifice and giving up of
the best up towards the purpose
and now below you have now the body now
the mother of God in this image Mary
represents the lower sphere she
represents the the body itself
and then next to her again you will have
Saint Peter
and Saint Paul
this is where my theory really comes
together because a lot of people like
yeah no these are just these are just
images of this they just wanted to find
a way to show the Ascension the get over
yourself it's not that complicated but
there's a little problem is that Saint
Paul was not at the Ascension
he just wasn't there so why is he there
and he's there universally there he's
represented not only universally at the
Ascension but University universally at
Pentecost as well
these are not snapshots of events
these are
eschatological images there are images
that show us a structure of reality
embodied in persons in the same way that
I told you about Dante and how Heaven is
made of people
this is what is going on in this in this
in these images now we don't deny the
the actual reality of these people they
have all their individuality all their
idiosyncrasy but in the manner in which
they engage in this pattern they become
like
concentrations of qualities
and then we see them represented that
way in the imagery okay
so we have
Christ above in the heavens
you have the mother below as the body
and now we have the two Tendencies on
each side which are pointing up
and gathered together
they're gathering together and they're
pointing up you want to go down one more
okay
I like this one because this one in
terms of the the biblical imagery is
very clear
now you have Christ sitting on the
heavens which is represented as a
rainbow and now you have the mother of
God standing on the footstool
okay
see
yeah the same Peter on the right of
Christ
they're harder to see
so we have a representation of the
relationship between Heaven and Earth
the relationship between what Saint Paul
talks about when he talks about the head
and the body when Saint Paul says that
we are fitted together joined together
fitted in love towards the head that's
not it's not an arbitrary thing this
happens in a way you could say these
images are there to show you how that
happens right the manner in which we are
both let's say
moving towards the heart moving away
from the heart in different ways moving
towards the logos moving away from the
logos in in different ways
now once you have this image
now you can do something really cool
with this image
this image you can do that you want to
go to the next one
you can do this
right you can explode it into 3D space
and now you have
a dome
on a square
you have the heavens and the footstool
you have Christ above in the dome
and then you will have and that in this
version The Dome is actually an image of
the Ascension it doesn't always have to
be that but originally this was actually
an image of the Ascension I want to go
down uh no maybe not go down right now
yeah yeah sorry go down so you can do it
that way you can have a dome and then in
the acts of the church which sorry I
don't I sadly I don't have an image but
in the apps of the church which is you
guys don't know probably most people
don't know how this how this happened so
you have a dome at the top and at the
top of the Dome you will have the
Heavenly man we'll talk about that later
you have the Incarnate man who
represents that point through which
Heaven comes right so he's above all the
angels all this stuff he's above all
things and then let's say the invisible
pattern comes through him and then
radiates into the square below and in
the Square you'll have what's called an
app at the end of the church in the East
you will have an image of Mary
with the child sometimes even without
the child so
you go down so now you could do it that
way or you could also do it for example
this way if you don't have a dome some
Churches don't have domes they just have
an apps at the end you could do it this
way which is the same
so you have Christ oh sorry go up
you have Christ above so this is now the
apps of the church you guys know what an
apps is the end of a church sometimes in
Old churches see like there's a
demi-circle it's like a mini Heaven you
could say like a little mini mini half
circle at the edge so you'll so you'll
have Christ above
sitting on a throne the four beasts
and then a below you have the body the
mother and then gathered into her you'll
have
Saint Peter St Paul and then all the
apostles gathered into the body
so it is a it is this Cosmic structure
you want to go down
I just wanted to show you so these are
some of my versions of the four uh the
four evangelists there's here one here
if you look if you go down at the
entrance of the church there's a an
image of the lion say mark
all right you can go down
so I just wanted to show you
different ways to do it
and so this this is an image of a church
in Cora we have Christ in the dome above
and then in the apps which I've shown
here you can't take a picture of it all
together the apps you'll have the mother
of God sitting on the throne as well
with Christ in her Center
uh
so it's also can I say this
I'm running out of time so I won't go
into it too much so keep going okay one
more image
so I just wanted to show you because I
full set into three I just want to show
you this last image which is
it can help you understand how it works
in terms of fractal structure
so the mystery
about this image about the structure is
that
it's the structure of a church
but it's also the structure of that one
icon I showed you of Jesus
with the with the hand and the book
everything about the whole iconography
of the church
all the saints and everything and all
this stuff it's all contained implicitly
in the one image okay so you can just
have an image of Christ and hidden
inside of it is all of this but then you
can blow it up and you can see how it
all fractally comes together there are
different ways to represent it here at
this church in torcello they have a very
powerful way of representing it
so above you have the Cross of Christ
Christ is dying on the cross on his
right hand he has his mother the left
hand you have Saint John The Foreigner I
St John the the the the
evangelist
and the thing is what's going on in this
image
what's going on in that image up there
is everything that is below it is
contained in the top image
contained in it and so
in the in the image of the crucifixion
we traditionally show a skull at the
bottom of the cross I don't know if you
can see it probably can see it you can
see a little white thing at the bottom
of the Cross right
so that's the skull of Adam and it is
it's an image of death being redeemed
but then that
happens
below here
go down right underneath you have What's
called the hair wing of Hades which is
an explicited image of Christ now going
down into death grabbing Adam and Eve
grabbing the dead and bringing them all
together into the one into the eschaton
into this totality of all things
and what what is the
what is that then it's what's below it
is the last judgment
so the image below is the image of the
last judgment where you see the Sheep on
the right the goats on the left people
rising up towards Christ on the right
people moving away from Christ on his
left
down there is hell
hell just fire and Brokenness and
inversion and breakdown on the other
side is Paradise which is gathering
together it's imaged in several ways as
Mary herself as the one that gathered
into her heart it's shown as Abraham
with all the all the children in his
bosom Gathering the children into
Abraham's bosom so these different
images of gathering these image of
breaking of burning of destroying
on the right side things they're going
up on the left side going down but the
idea
is that that was already there in the
cross in the story of the good and the
bad thief it was already all contained
in that little story because what does
Christ say to the good thief tomorrow
today you will be with me in Paradise
and he is right there by the way
this is the good thief sorry if you
can't see him it's too small the good
thief is actually represented in
Paradise the only person actually
represented in Paradise because all of
this is what's going on up there
so
my point
hopefully at least
is that you
understand how this language
is a language
an imaginal language of participation
in the very structure of our experience
at least you hopefully you can see that
and it's there in the very structure of
the image and the very understanding of
the characters and in the way in which
all these images fit into each other
they kind of collapse into each other
so that you could have just this image
of Jesus and it's all implicitly there
okay
so hopefully I didn't lose too many
people I'm sure I did thank you for your
time
[Music]
[Applause]